hello everyone Nikolai Rosa limo was an
American French Greek Russian Grand
Master oh yeah
and they called him the artist of chess
he defeated players like like F in
bhagavad Bronstein and Xu Wei and
managed to draw games against players
like josé raúl capablanca Bobby Fischer
and vasily smyslov so definitely quite a
guy and similarly to to measure matheno
but he won plenty of brilliant surprises
and best game awards and this games this
game he's playing against the polar ice
money it was played in 1967 in Puerto
Rico so let's see this
rosalie more artistry we have E for
Barroso limo and E 5 Wiseman tonight so
f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 the
Italian game Bishop to c5 and now c3
Knight to f6 b4e capture sandy for the
capture sandy for and Bishop to b4 check
and wrestling applies Bishop to d2 not
going for a knight c3 and trying to go
for the greco attack Bishop casters on V
- nice captures on D - and now d5 a very
strong move breaking breaking wide
center immediately he captures on d5 and
with a knife captors on d5 and Queen to
b3 now with a double attack on this
night so writing plays Knight C to e7
and there are solely no castles and we
have c6 roughly mogo's rook F to e 1 and
writing castles
and now a 4 and this a for a Rosalie
male uses as an attacking idea actually
to attack on the Kings side and you'll
see how he does it
we have b6 nice to e5 Bishop to d7
developing and now a 5 because now now
this one cannot be captured as the
bishop here would fall I would have
worked the c8 and our nice the e4 and
see how Rosalie mow gets his pieces
closer and closer to the enemy King we
have a king to c7 and now 86
pushing the bishop to 8 and the well
it's a very nice traditional move this
one will be good on a6 we have better
day 8 and now Russell emo plays Queen to
H
three bringing the Queen into the attack
and already you can see both Knights are
ready to jump into the attack this
Bishop is eyeing f7 Queen is I engage
seven something is well bound to happen
so ratmen gets an idea he plays Knight
to f4 with an attack on the Queen we
have Queen to g4 and now the other night
jumps into d5 so improving the position
of both nights and now Russell emo plays
rook to a3 and he's preparing the
maneuver rook to a3 and rook to g3 or h3
depending on depending on the position
and right hand says okay he's definitely
gonna play rub g3 and attack g7 I don't
really want to play g6 or oceanic bones
here to you know to mess up my bone
structure I'm going to play Knight to e6
and this protects Jesus g7 very nicely
but here Russell emo shows why he was
called the artist of chest
he plays Bishop captures and d5 we have
the C captures on d5 and now rustling go
plays Knight to f6 check of course the
knight can be captured as there's a pin
from the Queen and we have zinc to h8
and this is why I called the game the
American beauty of reversed because the
ruffle emo plays well there are a lot of
winning moves here but Rosa Lee mo
definitely plays the most beautiful
winning move he plays Queen to g6 and
similarly similarly to Frank Marshall
where he plays Queen to g3 with the
black pieces cutter salimos Queen is
also immortal here because let's see if
F captors on g6 you'll get nicely after
sun g6 would check there's the king can
go to GA so on the movies H chapter 76
an hour up to h3
checkmate of course and after Queen to
g6 is 8 phone captures and read page 3
is checkmate immediately
but even if black doesn't capture the
Queen for example if he captures the
knight with the G captures and f6 then G
Queen captures and f6 would check King
has to go to GA I mean King can go to g8
because of rope to g3 with checkmate he
has to play Knight to g7 and now rope
the g3 and how do you defend maintain g7
only move is rogue g8 and now comes
tonight to a nice characters on f7 would
check and
excessive of the Queen so the only thing
wrong with this game is that Paul
Reisman didn't resign in this position
like like Marshalls opponent did but he
played one more move Queen to c2 with
the hopes of defending this h7 square
with the Queen but Rosalie more simply
brings this rook finally in to h3 and in
this position polarizing resigned
because well the thread is now
definitely work captures on h7 with
checkmate and if even if black captures
the Queen with Queen captures then again
my capture screen with check and the
King can go anywhere we have F capture
some g6 and our rogue captures on h7 is
checkmate so yeah that's definitely a
beautiful game indefinitely
they called in the artist I mean it's
justified but I I would I would prefer
the game and the true Queen to g6
so yeah definitely a beautiful game and
yeah a beautiful case thank you all for
watching and as usual you can check to
my previous videos here but I will make
the top left video the original American
Beauty game by frank marshall if you
haven't seen it yet so the two guys
thank you all for watching and i will
see you soon